[Music]
hello i'm hannah hart and this is edible
history the show that takes our modern
mouths on a journey through time itself
today we'll be unwrapping the history of
tamales for those who may not come
across them often tamales are a staple
of latin american cuisine while i love
tamales i don't know anything about
their history yet which is why i'm
talking to claudia alaccon a food
historian with a special focus on mexico
can you tell me a little bit about the
origins of the tomah the earliest
evidence we have is from the maya area
the oldest thing they have found is a
mural in northern guatemala
that dates to about 200 bc in the
records that we have they show us like
round little balls today they're made
mostly flat or cylindrical wow so people
have been making tamales for almost
thousands of years it's a very ancient
food in mesoamerica can you tell me a
little bit about how they would prepare
them the maya did not leave recipe books
unfortunately for us
but we do know that they use the species
of animals and plants that were
available to them we can hypothesize
that of course they use the maize the
corn to make the masa and animal
proteins probably such as iguana or fish
or wild boar or turkey can you tell me a
little bit about how they would prepare
the masa this is a process that was
invented in the area of mesoamerica that
we refer to as nyx stomalization that
softens it and makes it easier to grind
and easier to digest and absorb the
nutrients within the corn so can you
tell us a little about the filling we'll
be making today the recipe we're making
today is a traditional
maya tamale that is called
poyo because you're trying to research
how things would have been made before
the conquest we're gonna be making it
with turkey which was an ingredient
readily available and endemic in the
maya area how do you think i'm gonna do
today i'm gonna go and i'm gonna start
grinding and i don't know what i'm gonna
finish i'm sure you're gonna do well
you're gonna have some strong arms to
grind that that corn with that stone
so the first step is mixtamalization
intimidating name intimidating process
mixtimalization is the process of
removing the husk from the corn and
making it workable and edible so here we
go
we take our beautiful white corn kernels
we add our water
and last but not least slacked lime now
i'm not referring to lime as in the
fruit i'm referring to lime as in
limestone this is calcium hydroxide
which is going to serve as the
activating agent in this process
when i picture masa i always picture it
as being kind of a yellowy powder but
this is pretty white oh wait oh my god
they're already turning yellow they're
changing color i did not expect this
[Music]
it's been about 30 minutes and wow this
thing has gotten even more yellow the
husks have completely dissolved i
thought that they would be here floating
in the water but they seem to have just
kind of melted away all right now we're
just going to set this aside
cover it up
and let it rest overnight
[Music]
and we're back welcome to day two of
making masa now we just got to remove
the corn and give it a quick rinse
before it's ready to grind this rinse
washes off the excess lime
now we're gonna strain it one more time
and that should be the last of it
alright let's get ready to grind
[Music]
let's get to grinding take a handful of
corn
all right
oh wow
this is gonna be hard
what's cool about this is that this is
the actual volcanic rock they would use
for the grinding the surface is the
perfect texture for this
oh my god
do we have enough for a tamale it can be
little
too small i can't imagine doing this for
hours
[Music]
all right
i could call myself a little bit of a
awesome master now we've got a lot a lot
of masa that we can work with check this
out the texture is really something that
like you just can't imitate this is
stone ground you know it takes a lot of
work to do this and people have to do
this every day for hours to feed each
other
that's amazing
[Music]
now it's time to make our filling we're
going with turkey a native of north
america and a tasty angry bird this is
three and a half pounds of just straight
up turkey breast oh gonna need two hands
okay i hope it fits in the pot
up next we're gonna be adding some
mexican oregano so we're gonna do a
small pinch of this
and next we're going to add specifically
four whole allspice berries
lastly a hearty pinch of salt and then
enough water to cover the turkey breast
and cook it for about
an hour you just want it to be tender
and you know falling off de bone do a
crossword a hard one that'll take like
an hour
all right now it's time to check on our
bird
that is a cooked looking turkey it's
time to start shredding
now we're gonna save some broth to use
later in the recipe
okay
i have to say making this filling has
been a fulfilling eggs burial
our next step involves thickening our
broth to do this it's actually pretty
cool first we're going to ladle out some
of the broth
and then we're going to thicken it using
our masa
we'll give that a nice little stir and
let it start to heat up
while that's heating up we're going to
make our blend of herbs and spices small
caveat we don't know exactly what herbs
and spices they would have used for
their seasoning so we're going to go
with peppercorn salt and achiote which
is
wild i've actually never cooked with
this before let's grind up our
peppercorn
a little pinch of salt shabang
and all of our achiote paste
[Music]
and blend it all together
that is such a gorgeous color so we've
got all of our elements now it's just
time to bring them all together
so now we are in our tamal home stretch
everybody it's only been a smooth five
hours and we're getting closer oh wait
it's also been a full night of sleep
wow these take a minute so our next
steps involve going back to our turkey
broth we're gonna add about three
tablespoons of liquid
onto the fun part so
how many of you know what this is
this is a habanero pepper it is one of
the hottest peppers on the scroble scale
because of that i'm gonna put some
gloves on to ensure my safety
okay we're going to slice it in half
then we're going to remove the seeds and
now we're going to chop it up just a
little
and then place our pepper in our little
brothy do the most dangerous part of
this whole meal is over next we'll be
adding an herb called episote also give
this a rough chop
voila
now we are going to remove our gloves
avoid touching the board
and add
bye-bye gloves all done with you
just don't want to let go
it's my show next we're going to add our
seasoning
[Music]
now we're going to give it a quick
little stir
to kind of let it you know saturate get
to know each other mingle next we'll be
adding our tomatoes
gonna give these a gentle stir and then
last but not least we're going to add
our turkey
we're going to mix it all together and
let these flavors marry ah beautiful
phrase
all right look at that color
oh i wanna eat it so bad and last but
not least we're gonna add our thickened
broth so we're gonna give this a hearty
stir set it aside and then finally we
can start assembling our tamales i gotta
say guys making all that masa was a real
grind
[Applause]
so here we are the home stretch the
tamal
phenol
first we're going to wet our masa with
broth your goal is to get it to the
consistency of kind of a pie dough
now the masa itself is also pretty wet
it retains moisture really well so if
you look it clumps together pretty
easily okay now we're going to kind of
knead it together you can try lots of
things but don't use my kneading method
i'm not a good kneader it's hard to
express what you need right now we have
every element that we've been working
with and it's time to bring them all
together we've got our delicious looking
filling our great totally worth the
effort masa our broth which just seems
to come in handy all the time and now
the final element
[Music]
right now in its raw state
it's not
as flexible it's a little breakable and
that's really not something we want to
work with the trick is to take a banana
leaf and gently run it over a very high
heat this makes it more pliable check it
out oh that is so cool
careful not to burn it or you
see
huh
whoa
what a bendy friend now it's time to
finally assemble we're going to take a
handful of our masa we're going with
around a shape like claudia mentioned
now we're going to take our wrapper
place it matte side up shiny side out
and then add our filling i think
theoretically you can like kind of pinch
it all together but
i'm just gonna put another layer of moss
on top i mean this masa was a lot of
work so i'm gonna use as much of it as
possible put a layer on top
and then kind of pack it all in
let me just seal up these edges
now it looks kind of like a biscuit
and voila a little tamale ball
we're gonna place it in our leaf flatten
it just a touch and then wrap it like a
package
hey i mean not so bad it's kind of like
the first pancake moment you know it's
the experiment next we're gonna take our
banana leaf string warm it up a little
bit
and tie it all together
and voila
set this aside make some more and then
later i'll show you how to steam it
our last little tamale
now originally tamales were steamed
underground unfortunately since i could
not dig a hole here no matter how much i
asked politely multiple times we're
gonna have to just pour some water in
this pot and throw it in the oven all
right
let's get steamy
[Music]
it's time for tamales i could not be
more excited to eat this let's see how
they turned out
oh baby baby
i can smell the corn
but then it's also got that floral hint
coming from the banana leaf okay
oh i mean they look awesome but frankly
we won't really know until we unwrap
these bad boys
i gave it my all and i got a tamale
okay nice
okay
good
wow
it's rustic tasting it's a little earthy
tasting
but it's really satisfying wow
i know i just keep saying wow but
i kind of love it i think i like banana
leaf wrap tamales the masa acts like its
own part of the meal i have to say that
the modern day tamales i've had don't
have as much masa flavor it blends
beautifully
my palette
super happy
what else is there to say besides
that's a wrap
thank you so much for watching this
episode of edible history i hope that
you like me never look at tamales the
same way